yeah Alyssa come on hurry up
gosh wait wait quick me wait are you
doing that's great it's great yeah this
is really worth it right now okay okay
stop more stop I'm gonna do order to
watch I'm Ryan this is Alyssa turn it
off all right he's a a hunchback dude
I've been pressing the refresh button on
Twitter and this thing since friggin
5:45 and I'm stoked
blasting speakers
who are you I'm no one I'm so many
goosebumps I was raised to do one thing
whoa
I've got nothing to fight for nothing
stand in our way
finish who do you start
those stories what would happen
you
the dark side Wow
the real
you
the force it's calling to you
just editing
no [ __ ] tickets are now available
[ __ ] Internet's I'm [ __ ] working
cuz I'm away forever it's been [ __ ]
like three hours of me refreshing a
goddamn Fandango beside
he's been refreshing the Fandango site
I've been sitting here freshies to watch
the bridge are you trying to buy I need
to watch that again cuz I'm like I was
so like oh my god Star Wars a whole side
of that brain that I was like wait
what's going on all right
Oh like I had goosebumps the entire time
like oh yeah as Laura's a little bit it
just has the signature Star Wars look it
does it's it feels so it doesn't feel
like it doesn't fit
yeah so did I get fat Disney was saying
it's it's Star Wars like this is ha
she's beautiful
read yes
I was raised to do one thing
it's gonna be an epic 5 into 4 music
started our way
fish I think you started what your story
he's give anything new gallery a person
a
I just want to get every moment of this
truth out
the dark side god it feels like the
originals
they're real
the force it's calling to you
just betadine just let it him I remember
when I said those words to my girlfriend
ah the force awakened at that moment let
me tell you we were both pretty forceful
that's what I got from the Star Wars
trailer wow what a beautiful [ __ ]
trailer I just want to get lost in this
world all over again um straight like
watch that for hours hours on repeat
tonight I can't I cannot get over this I
just love how it looks like the original
Star Wars trilogy Enoch you know that
feels like Star Wars
see one of the let downs to me of the
first three episodes was that it felt so
teton more technologically advanced it
seemed like a distant cousin to Star
Wars the story got lost to the
technology it was like oh look what we
can do all the things instead of hey
this is Star Wars it's awesome I feel
like this is going back to creating an
epic story you know the technology to
support the story and not the other way
around I'm really excited for that I
mean it looks like they're giving us
what we really want yeah you know like
we're getting new interesting characters
for sure I want to know more about who
john boyega's playing you know it looks
like he's going down the Luke Skywalker
path cuz I won't point Luke Skywalker
was you know storm dressed as a
stormtrooper
he was really a Jedi maybe this could be
Luke Skywalker's um you know black child
this could be his child out of wedlock
head Assessor I'm thinking Luke
Skywalker had sex with a black chick
have that black child out of wedlock
totally cheated again um who knows we
have to way to find out even just a
trailer like from the glimpse it's not
even even like a huge thing but like the
glimpse that we got feels like it has a
story trailers don't usually feel like
they have a story it's like oh hey this
is the thing that's happening and this
is the thing you should watch but this
is something that you could watch over
and over and over and it's still
exciting I died I don't even fully
fathom that this is actually happening
sort of seems like a fan-made trailer to
me it's like I'm saying that in a great
way you know when you see like a
great like fan-made trailer and you're
like I wish this was real
yes know what the fans yeah and I feel
like this movie is being created by fans
and it's all in support and dedication
to the fans you know that's why they
know how to bring back the original cast
you know they're really I know and love
that the original cast is coming back or
a lot of it from what I understand
yeah they got Han Solo in there for the
trailer Princess Leia we've heard more
camels voice and the other one so yeah I
want they're also telling like the story
to the new characters like no these were
legends you know gets you to think about
Star Wars and how we experienced that
growing up and now they're bringing it
back and we're like well yeah Star Wars
was legendary but what I'm wondering is
like yeah it's legendary and obviously
it's like legendary for for these
characters in the film but what I'm
curious about is that they say like
they've heard stories and like yeah it's
legend did the force leave like or not
leave but like has it gone undetected
like is something happening where the
force is coming back and it's just been
like not there to me what I'm picking up
on is that Return of the Jedi is when
the war ended and it seems like another
war is about to happen someone who wants
to carry on Darth Vader's legacy right
and fulfill the dark prophecy or
whatever right so I feel like so many
years have gone by that people have sort
of forgotten about our heroes that's the
idea behind what JJ Abrams does so well
it's he knows how to build so much
mystery and intrigue to a story that
we're not so clear what it's about yet
he knows how to hype it in such a way
where you're like I gotta find out
what's going on it looks like they're
honoring the original Star Wars and
updating it in terms of visual imagery
in the right moments like they're
keeping a lot of the practical effects a
lot of the suits and stuff look very
similar to the original they're not like
completely changing it now but they're
adding better visual style with
cinematography better visual action
sequences and the feel like they're
adding at the right moments right and
but they're still honoring the original
look a lot right which I I'm very
grateful for that I just feel like a lot
of hell's gonna break loose in this film
you know like you got they got so much
imagery of like ah like people yelling
crying han Solo and / and
in a lair like hugging each other and
then he like starts pushing her head
down because he wants a [ __ ] remember
that part they cut they cut to the next
scene right before we saw you ruining a
audience so much dick don't do that
don't do that you know what
han Solo said to Chewie he said hey
Chewie you want to DP this or you want
me to go Han Solo on this oh I don't
know ty my mystery woman I'm really
interested to see who the bad guy is
really interested to see the bad guy is
he JJ Abrams for the most part he knows
how to create great villains memorable
villains you know mission impossible 3
and Benedict Cumberbatch and star trek
into darkness I feel like this guy knows
how to do an out of capture villains
well this villain I'm really entry like
after all these years who's like I
really want to carry on Darth Vader's
with his Darth Vader have another kid
Queen Amidala had Luke Skywalker and
Leia and then the Anakin Skywalker was
just lonely in the in space for like
20-something years but the dudes gonna
get a little horny you know he's gonna
unleash the force in some way oh my god
stop show them his dark side know what I
mean yeah sounds like I was like he's
doing this without consent
sorry goodness I really want to know
that the fight scene with John boyega in
the end and I don't know the darkness if
Thor whatever whoever the Darkseid guy
is that looks like such an epic fight
because you could really see the body
language in their fight how the the bad
guy is like [ __ ] just [ __ ] you I'm
walking up to you and then even though
he website is his lightsaber to defend
himself he's still like scared and it's
like I gotta do this it really feels
like a hero you can relate with already
well the thing is too is that we've seen
bits and pieces from this scene for like
a year like the first I think it was one
of the first if not the first glimpse of
this one of this whole movie that we saw
was just a couple of seconds from that
scene there's something really
significant and I
just some excited yeah I wanna that
probably might be the scene everyone's
gonna be walking out of the theater
talking about oh yeah something tells me
it's gonna be that scene anyway guys
thanks for saying that trailer actually
none of you said that I'd rely on you
guys to tell me when the trailers are
out and you fail you fail I have to
refresh the pages filter searches to
find this [ __ ] trailer but thank you
anyway guys for watching
now if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and become
a reject a bot today that what we're
going about right reject ina Oh get your
Rick Jack Dinah [ __ ] and yet Alyssa be
crazy DUP on the Alyssa be crazy channel
confusing music I follow us on all our
social networks you know the Facebook
the instagrams of Twitter is the fave
all that [ __ ] let's do a shout out
you like chance hey Ryan can I get a
shoutout I've been watching your awesome
videos a few months now you're cool and
keep with the great work from your new
friend Eli also XD also which movie are
you more excited for Civil War or Batman
V Superman huh Batman V Superman
come on Marvel dishes at a new movie
like every three months you like chance
you know what man I'm gonna take a
chance here a lot of subscribers look
like serial killers no Joe I'm gonna see
if Eli chance looks like a Siri does not
look like a serial killer
Fred it looks like we could be looks
like John boyega see this is good this
is good you know you got John boyega you
know leading the new Star Wars film and
I got Eli chance we're gonna close out
this video with a subscriber who is
black this is good this is good this is
about time I redeem myself because
people think I'm racist sometimes but
I'm trying to prove Eli you're helping
me give a chance an Eli chance to prove
I'm not racist dog Thank You Holmes
shoutout to you my brother from another
mother I still don't think you look like
a serial killer so well I don't think he
does either so I you my bro mm-hmm word
do that just fair fair
I do my thing okay let me do my thing I
want to do a thing oh yeah so much prep
time hahaha I'm gonna be that person
sitting behind you in the theater I am
sorry I apologize in advance but this is
so happy I'm excited
I'm totally bringing this to the theater
and we be that one person just waving it
around